Німеччина - одна з тих країн, де квартиранти мають
набагато більше прав, ніж власники нерухомості.
Обов’язків в них теж вистачає, але
законодавство вибудуване таким чином,
що люди по 10-15 років можуть комфортно і стабільно
жити в одному орендованому помешканні.
Усе - і  права, і обов’язки - прописані в договорі про оренду.
Без нього ключі вам не дадуть.
Найголовніше ваше право - це спокійно жити
в орендованому помешканні, не боячись, що
з наступного місяця вас раптово виселять.
Річ у тому, що в Німеччині неможливо вигнати
квартирантів без поважної причини.
Якщо ви нічого не порушуєте, попросити вас
"на вихід" зможуть, лише якщо сам власник захоче
жити у квартирі - а не його племінник чи знайомий.
Чим довше ви там живете, тим раніше власник
повинен вас попередити - інколи за рік чи півтора.
Якщо будинок чи квартиру, в якій ви мешкаєте, продали -
новий господар також не має права вас вигнати,
старий договір оренди продовжує діяти,
його навіть перепідписувати непотрібно.
Так само власник не має права підвищувати
квартплату просто так – хіба що зробив ремонт,
поставив нову сантехніку, поміняв вікна чи дах.
Підняти плату лише тому, що гроші потрібні,
не вийде, бо закон вимагає орієнтуватися
на вартість житла у регіоні, яка вказана в офіційних довідниках.
Навіть більше: квартиронаймач може вимагати зменшення
платні, якщо в квартирі щось зламалося, а власник не полагодив.
При чому самовільно заходити в ваше помешкання
він теж не може - лише у випадку надзвичайної ситуації
або з рішенням суду і поліцією.
Священний обов'язок німецьких квартиронаймачів
– вчасно платити оренду.
Не заплатити оренду навіть за два місяці або платити,
але невчасно - найпевніший спосіб таки позбутися квартири.
Інші варіанти - грубо порушувати порядок в будинку та псувати майно.
Наприклад, з 10-ї вечора до 6-ї ранку, а також
у неділю та релігійні свята заборонено галасувати і заважати сусідам.
Натомість решту часу - їхні скарги можна майже ігнорувати.
Крім цього, в кожному багатоквартирному будинку
існують правила внутрішнього розпорядку.
Вони регулюються графік прибирання під'їзду і сходів,
користування підвалом або спільним гаражем.
Він же визначає, що в коридорі тримати сміття
і велосипеди не можна, а приміром - дитячі візочки - без проблем.
За систематичне порушення - також можуть попросити.
Інші важливі обов'язки: повідомляти про поломки
в квартирі та навіть користуватися опаленням!
Інакше взимку з'явиться пліснява і зіпсуються труби,
що потягне за собою коштовний ремонт.
Ну і останнє - в багатьох договорах прописана
заборона на суборенду помешкання та переїзд
до вас друзів чи коханих - про все це треба
попереджати або й просити дозволу у власника.
Для німців усі ці чіткі правила здаються зручними та виправданими.
Крім того, інтереси орендарів захищає надзвичайно
впливовий "Союз захисту прав квартирантів".
Ще й тому більше половини мешканців Німеччини
віддають перевагу саме оренді житла, а не купівлі.